>> Hi YouTube. I'm Carl Ganter from Circle
of Blue at the World Economic Forum in Davos
and we are trying to answer the one question,
the one priority, well, I'll give you two.
One is to raise awareness and develop the
will to respond to the global freshwater crisis.
Now we have a very complicated crisis with
so many different intersection points from
finances to climate to general watershed management
to biodiversity but how do we respond? How
do we unify everyone? We understand that we
have the solutions; we have many, many different
options, we have great challenges and what
I'm told here and elsewhere is that the missing
piece, the really piece of this puzzle, is
building the will and building the awareness
to respond so I think if we can do that, we
can help solve on the greatest challenges
that faces us on Earth.